in this lecture sequence we will do a
lot with normal random variables and for
this reason it is useful to start with a
simple observation that will allow us
later on to move much faster
recall that normal random variable with
a certain mean and variance has a PDF of
this particular form
what if somebody gives you a PDF of this
form and asks you what it corresponds to
you can answer that this is exactly of
this form provided that you make the
identification that 3 is equal to mu so
this is a normal PDF with a mean equal
to 3 and whose variance can also be
found by matching this constant that
appears here with a number 8 this
constant here is in the denominator so
we have a term 1 over 2 Sigma squared
this must be equal to 8 and from this we
can infer that the variance of this
random variable is equal to 1 over 16
and if you also want to find out the
value of this constant C you check the
formula for normal PDFs the constant C
is 1 over the standard deviation which
is 1/4 in our case the square root of
this number times the square root of 2
pi now suppose that somebody gives you a
PDF of this form it's a constant times
the negative exponential of a quadratic
function in X we will argue that this
PDF is also a normal PDF and identify
the parameters of that normal first
let's start with a certain observation a
PDF must integrate to 1 so it cannot
blow up as X goes to infinity which
means that this exponential needs to die
out as X goes to infinity and that will
only happen if this coefficient alpha
here is positive so that we have e to
the minus something positive and large
which is going to die out therefore we
must have alpha being a positive
constant and let us assume from now on
that this is the case what we will do
next is we will try to
right this PDF in this form and the
trick that we're going to use is the
following we will focus on the term in
the exponent which we rewrite this way
we take out a factor of alpha and then
we will try to make this expression here
appear like a square of this kind like a
perfect square so what is involved is a
certain method a certain trick called
completing the square that is we write
this term here in the form X plus
something squared and then we may need
some additional terms what should that
something be we would like that
something be such that when we expand
this quadratic we get this term and that
term well we get an x squared and then
there's going to be a cross term what do
we need here so that the cross term is
equal to this what we need is a term
equal to beta over 2 alpha because in
that case the cross term is going to be
2 times X times beta divided by 2 alpha
the 2 in the beginning and that to
cancel out so we're left with X beta
over alpha which is exactly what we got
here however this quadratic is going to
have an additional term which is going
to be the square of this which is not
present here so to keep the two sides
equal we need to subtract that term and
finally we have the last term involving
gamma therefore the PDF of X is of the
form we have a certain constant from
here then we have the negative
exponential of this term e to the minus
alpha
X plus beta over 2 alpha squared and
then there's the negative exponential of
the rest which is going to be a term of
the form e to the minus alpha times beta
squared over 4 alpha squared plus gamma
over alpha now this term here does not
involve any X's so it can be absorbed
into the constant C the dependence on X
is only through this term and now this
term looks exactly like what we've got
up here provided that you make the
following identifications mu has to be
equal to what we have here but here's
there's a man who signs you there's no
minus sign and so mu is going to be the
negative of what we have up here it's
minus beta over 2 alpha and as for Sigma
squared we match and say that 1 over 2
Sigma squared must be equal to the
constant that we have up here which is
alpha and from this we conclude that
Sigma squared is equal to 1 over 2 alpha
so we have concluded that a PDF of this
type is indeed a normal PDF it has a
mean equal to that value and the
variance equal to that value actually to
figure out what the mean of this PDF is
we do not need to go through this whole
exercise once we're convinced that this
is a normal PDF then we know that the
mean is equal to the peak of the PDF to
find the peak we want to maximize this
over all X's which is the same as
minimizing this quadratic function over
all X's where is this quadratic function
minimized to find that place we can look
at the exponent take its derivative and
set it to 0
so setting the derivative of the
exponent to zero gives us the equation
two Alpha X plus beta equal to zero and
from this we solve for X and we can tell
that the peak of the distribution is
going to be when X takes this particular
value this value must also be equal to
the mean so this is a very useful fact
to know and we will use it over and over
negative exponential of a quadratic
function of X is always a normal PDF